another absolute giant uh richard pryor
you and i have discussed richard pryor
because i've asked you over the years
uh various uh intimate questions i asked
you who was your favorite all-time
comedian you said it was richard pryor
you said richard pryor was your favorite
stand-up
well i used to say ripples you know
because well i had to say rickles right
[Laughter]
because he was usually right there you
know you had to say reckless
but secretly uh i know i think prior
prior without question was the most
influential stand-up and uh
in the past 50 years i mean you just
have guys
doing the prior he was uh he was
brilliant
i used to say he was like i got the mark
twain
award and i think it was
2006 or something like that and uh
i i then he then richard got it
and kind of what what what mark twain
did and what
what friar did with the two things with
this the same thing because
mark twain was describing life in the
mississippi
on in effect the frontier at the turn of
the
of the 19th century uh
yeah and um and prior was describing
life
in the inner city at the turn of the
20th century so there were
so i i i gave him an award one time i
mean i was
i presented him with an award george
slaughter had a
a lifetime achievement award and richard
uh got it and i i handed it to him he
was in the wheelchair at that point so
we went to commercial we came back and
he and i were just standing there
and he looked up and he looked up at me
and he said uh
i stole your record he stole it he stole
which one button down mind was it
buttoned down i said
what'd you say he said i i stole your
album
so i was in peoria illidor and
i went into a record store and i i put
it in my jacket
so that that was there's no higher
tribute than
richard pryor saying richard pryor stole
your album
i i don't think there is a higher
tribute what did you say to him when he
told you that he had stolen your album
i said you know i said well richard i
said
you owe me a quarter i said i got a
quarter for each album
and he said who's got a quarter give me
a quarter
to me i still have it i still haven't
afforded richard program